[музика]
Я зовсім
не очікувала і не розуміла що це може
відбуватися і ще так масштабний
до останнього ми не вірили ми не вірили
Я думав це буде чергове якесь брязкання
зброєю потім стало зрозуміло що виявився
Я не готовий до цього не моя родина
[музика]
дисциплину холоднокровья
Микола зовсім не хотів чути щоб залишати
місто щоб евакуватися кудись сюжети
14-го года и прошли это нелёгкий путь не
до того чтобы наш город взяли орки себе
він очікував тобто я так розумію повинно
бути підкріплення або війська може наші
зайти або якісь я знаю коли він уже
поняв що зрозумів що
підтримки не буде що вони сюди зайдуть
Оце він все розумів
розумів що вже з мацевурою це питання
вирішити неможливо
сегодня всем 30 поступил звонок от
командиров батальйону российских воск о
предложении переговоров
иначе город будет штурмовать со всеми
последствиями я принял решение
участок переговоров дабы избежать
человеческий жертв и разрушением городе
Ми там говорили
действия военных которые ставят целью
зайти в город
будет порядок в городе
[музика]
тут такі люди дуже працьовиті ніколи не
було тут таких людей які
про щось мріяли недоступне
всі ж думають периферия кто знает Где
можно творится что угодно а потом же с
этой периферии у нас появляются
непонятно Кто и рассказывают про русские
[музика]
йому дуже хотілося щоб у місті
завод він має працювати
з Миколою ми познайомилися під час
виборів і його округ підпадав під те
місце де я працювала ось таке було
знайомство на рівні праці співпраці але
ж Потім почали бачитися та
зустрічатися дружити скажемо так
він настільки був впевнений що Україна
переможе і що ми не допустимо цього що
він і не вірив
він був і все від депутата але ж
був таким знаєте людина
до людей він ніколи не був якимось
недоступним
депутатам мабуть чиновником
завжди казав що ніколи не залишу
Куп'янськ він не любить великі міста то
есть якось от він відчував що куп'янське
це його місто
після того як
місто було вже здано
він
дуже пав духом він розумів що це вже все
в якомусь місці або в містах вийшли люди
спілкувалися з військовими які зайшли в
місто і військові покинули місто Ну а
щось таке мріяв щось таке зробити
першим ділом Микола потрапив до офісу
для того щоб взяти прапор України
і щоб його підняти я спілкуюся з Колею
він таким турбованим голосом каже що
приходь на мітинг бери камеру все що
необхідно обов'язково
[оплески]
люди вийшли з подвалів ви розумієте що у
людей в голові було які сиділи четверо
суток там в підвалі да ось ми висів
вийшли
[музика]
чоловік 300 прийшло жінки чоловіки
все Україна
буде все Україна
вокруг нас з автоматами стоять отам
стоять отам вони з машинами були
[оплески]
[музика]
Україна героя
конфлікт
вийшли з мирною акції ми хотіли
розібратися чому ви тут
Почему мы сюда приехали сейчас на
местные показывают как бомбят города мы
не понимаем Что происходит и мы уже
хотим домой не вірили в те що Можливо
таке що сейчас нас тут по Україні будуть
всі вбивати
Ось так ми тут всі спускалися
[музика]
він пішов вперед і коли ми ось сюди де
дійшли і ось якраз ось цього переулку
вони отстояли російська армія
[оплески]
вони не хочуть розмовляти з миром вони
не хочуть іти з нашої землі з миром
потім як Дим зупинився ми побачили що
Коля немає
[музика]
Вони знали якщо заберуть масля а люди
заспокоюються Ось так і вийшло ми
требуємо показать нам средствах масової
інформації запись
масляя Николая Николаевича что он жив
[музика]
пришли военкомат закрыли военкомат
первый день
и я пошел он там и это матне оружие
немеем я вот здесь отдел с бабами с
одним
утром днём ночь я сам поехал сам один
поехал и всё
[музика]
всё
[оплески]
перший поверх це районна адміністрація
другий третій поверх це міська рада була
все
[музика]
ось це мій кабінет був
той день коли куплять було окуповано що
міський голова оголосив що будуть
заходити сюди російські війська
товариства в цьому кабінеті це відділ і
писали Ось там стояв стол робочий і від
там де на запис
рішення за мною ответственно за всё что
происходит в городе лежит на мне
ну це була його ошибка
коли писалось відео Ми всі були на
роботі
Тобто ми працювали не для когось як там
деякі кажуть А ви ось ви місцева Влада
що ви там робили треба було тікати чи не
треба А Люди
приходять люди плачуть отакими слізами
поможіть
елементарна видача якийсь садові так
Люди вмирали життя не встановили
сліди потрібно було лікувати
колапс повний колапс
фактично як такого і співпраці їх тут не
було у військовій формі тут їх не було
Ну ми працювали за українськими законами
під корейськими печатками
всеукраїнський абсолютно все
Я не хочу показувати своє обличчя я
боюсь що вони сюди ще раз йдуть з перших
днів вона з керівник прийшов і сказав
тепер тільки на російській мові тепер
тільки за Росію Я не зголосилася сказала
що працювати не буду гуманітарну
допомогу від них брати не буду А він
сказав буде тобі погано
організований
обладает таким качеством как займало
ручка
і в нас надіюсь ждет
уха хороша
починається обшуки приїхали в 6 ранку
вибили мені двері Я у вікно глядь
під'їжджає два буса вивалюється куча
військових дитина в паніці кричить Не
забирайте мені маму Я виходжу Він
відкриває паспорт такий
черемской поехали Ну вони не люди і вони
начинають дитині то я мама не приїде
більше Вот все і закрили мене все
одиночна камера №9 завели мене в підвал
почали мене допитувати де ваші атовці
ховають у місті було чутно що були
сильно билих атошника нашого в мене
значить поперла
мыслі мысли мысли мысли мысли в том
плане что що дальше я питалась спокойно
і вони навіть розуміли поки не прийшов
один з них Який Ну відімо у чоловіка з
головою печально полностью сказав що ви
з нею розмовляєте бийте Ну тут почалась
звісно жесть були і током і руками
ногами
окупанти коли заходили до населених
пунктів вони дійсно шукали ті місця які
можна пристосувати для організації
штабів організації незаконних місць
неволі катівень
[музика]
глобальніша котівня - це саме
райвідділок облаштовані для утримання
людей тому вона була наймасовіша
[музика]
камери яка розрахована на двох можливо
могло бути до 6-8 осіб
саме страшне Це виявляється Сам ти Тобто
ти своїми думками настільки себе
залякуєш
в камерах затриманим роздавали гімн
Російської Федерації
патріотичні пісні
Радянського Союзу мушули їх вивчати
потім співати
[музика]
вони мене допитали побили значить зняли
мене на відео і таким чином вони мене
завербували і сказали щоб я нікуди не
вдумав тікати щоб я прийшов до них
приходив до них через кожних три дня і
розповідав їм про те що мені відомо там
про зброю або якісь там організовані
групи
Я нікого не зрадив я вже знав кого не
було в місті і ну судячи з того як було
найкраще я називав тих людей яких уже
точно я знав не було в місті
після того як закінчився мітинг Я їздила
туди додому там де проживала його родина
Привіт дружок
такі ощущение ми ж пішли до туди де його
забрали на цей блокпост і просили що
передати йому хоча б там якісь речі і та
ліки і вони дали згоду Так приносьте
завтра приносьте ось А коли ми приїхали
їм принесли це
вони сказали що нічого брати не будуть
що його вже звідси вивезли
в школі на бухгалтерія
чекала його тиждень вважала що Ось він
явиться явиться і потім я виїхала і все
[музика]
я викладав інформаційні технології
технології ну це щось щось схоже на
труди звичайні і географію і геолокацію
Ну звичайно інструкція були нові ми мали
Скажімо так нас ніхто не змушував цього
можна було тихенько просто промовчати і
все не казати Нічого я займався можу
можу сказати програми Не було нічого не
було в мене були мої старі
щоб по чому я працював Раніше там тести
українською мовою там загальні такі
поняття що ну в тому з дітьми там сиділи
розв'язували який найбільший водоспад в
світі і таке в такому іншому
діти навпаки їм більше я кажу Ну я як ми
будемо як ми треба буде спілкуватися
вони кажуть ти Давайте так давайте
давайте українською ми нікому не скажемо
давай оту сідушку отак от поклади її
так Васильович
як тільки туди допускали людей ми саме в
Куп'янськ Просто приїхали ще не знали
нікого різати по коробке каждого Ну
давай каждого возьмём
потім ще я познайомилась з людмилою і то
вже більш тісніше стало так спілкуватися
так все
[музика]
О а оце якраз Мої приїхали
волонтьори які
люди Ми ж на ковшарівку їдемо так
хоч там і пічку взяли і продукти
з Богом
шановні харків'яни шановні наші Воїни з
міста Куп'янська виїжджають фашисти
російські зустрічайте їх бомбітів
розбивайте ми знаємо що Україна переможе
і наші воїни непереможні перемога за
нами Ну що ж’їжджаєте зараз вас
зустрінуть
Сирена Я всем утра вийшла за молоком я
бігом гортатися бо в мене ребенок на
четвертому этаже бігом додому ну
А сніг випав з кольца
приземлилась Тепер я з гіпсом
ми домовилися ще раз зустрічатися
виходили через декілька днів але люди
вже не прийшли я зрозуміла що далі
мітингів ми вже проводити не будемо
далі ми займались допомагати гуманітарно
до мене сюди постучали два хлопці з ми
довго друга дивилися Ну а потім уже
зрозуміли що ми всі нормальні люди
сказали що починаємо і ми починали ну
начала писати люди начали відкликатися і
допомагати
тут не топилися бачите квіти пропали
деякі
банки тушонки на яких було написано
Слава Україні Слава ЗСУ якби хоч один
пакет вони відкрили б і побачили
Тобто Це все було партизанське Для нас
це була знаєте як вістка Що Ми заносимо
людям і вони чують голос з України Щоб
ви не забуті що ми всі разом от Для нас
це було дуже велике значення
чекали ми чекали наших
воїнів-захисників де ж уже втомилися
тому що кожен день коли вони прийдуть
Коли вони прийдуть і люди всі розуміли
що тут уже дуже багато цих орків дуже
багато скопилось їхніх військ і ми
понімали що тут буде больно і за мною
чоловік тут казав що вивезе дитини що ти
хочеш жити
[музика]
[сміх]
щастя спокою Господи помолімося Господи
помилуй ходячи від тебе це світле тебе
слабо подяку поклоніння віддаємо оцю і
сину і Святому духу Є нині повсякчас і
на віки вічні
Амінь
хто подорожуючих приймах переселенці
виїхали з тих страшних місць де
неможливо жити і без копійки навіть без
документів І хто це все чинить так то
безперечно той увійде до Царства Божого
так що надіємося що
що нас іще є то та Жага до боротьби і
Жага до життя і жага звичайно не тільки
вижити а і перемогти Слава Ісусу Христу
боже благословення
купатися було дуже складною морально
треба було не забувати Хто ти є
Якби хтось із них зайшов в церкву нашу
на службу і почув як ми молимося за нашу
армію щоб з нами було відомо
наших вірянах я був впевнений але на
велике свято на троїцю
приїжджали приходили людей же ж більше і
ніхто не ніхто не дає
так
Але у нас була купка людей які
продовжували боротися продовжували
доходити до храму через два місяці після
війни після початку війни Я питаю може
щось треба робити Давайте
Якось треба з цим боротися І ми вирішили
організувати невеличку партизанську і ми
разом кожної неділі після служби
збиралися і коригували наші дії
[музика]
дуже багато людей на жаль
вірили що Росія принесе тут мир помий
підрахункам 25% 30% це були проросійські
люди на жаль в нас таке селище з таким
населенням у нас будувався завод і дуже
багато людей з Радянського Союзу
приїжджали сюди
ну от що ми можемо робити по суті
чоловіки з автоматами ходять Ну і що нам
довелося використовувати те що було в
мене був принтер спочатку починаємо з
трьох листівок потім пішов до 10
листівок далі
перші листівки Ми робили Саме тут
на такому матеріалі на погано тримається
в принципі на камені
краще клеїти скотчем треба було не
видавати себе робити все так як роблять
інші Ну є ж люди які там приклеюють
листівку там
даю машину ще там я не знаю просто
спокійно ніби ти нічого незаконного не
робиш підійти приклеїти спокійно піти
ніхто тебе не буде
дуже важливо було передавати координати
тому що це дуже сильно вплинуло на
Харківський наступ який був ну був
суддяшим зробили Що не можемо сказати
точно на що це вплинула як сильно але це
війна і навіть якась маленька справа
зроблена під час війни вона складається
у рушійний водопад
Ну звісно у нас були проросійські
одногрупники в нас був хлопчик на курс
молодший який
прославився в наших краях що із дерев
український прапори він е-е був активно
проросійський Ви розумієте ну
Пропаганда На жаль робить свою справу
молодёж Харьковской области беспощадок
символ нацистской Украины потому что
больше не желает его себя
коли був гімназії вмикали і гімн України
це пафосний патріотизм був сказали Так
діти всі тримають руку на них на серці
Да і співайте
багато людей співали але коли прийшла
війна чогось не такі вже й потрібно
розумієте А ти знаєш гімн
так Ну давайте
ще нам браття українці у
[музика]
всіх з
гинули дружити
пожалуйста
[музика]
промивали Мозги місцевого населення
Це було в травні місяці я намагався
подзвонити своїм рідним дуже поганий
зв'язок був Ну десь біля 21 години я
вийшов на біля батьків був подзвонити Я
був затриманий за начебто
порушення комендантської години
основного питання було розповідай кажу
що розповідати згадуй що і
скажемо так застосовували не дозволений
метод мішок на голову руки ноги скотч на
обличчя шапка скотч зверху
кажуть займай
зручну позицію
два провода
и вперёд
струм і побиття
[музика]
сталий имя главы временные Гражданская
администрации Под контролем российским
военнослужащим территории Харьковской
области
на власним рішенням собрания
Гражданской администрации Харьковской
области и избранчук Віталій
Константинович
[оплески]
[музика]
тільки-тільки надруковані Таке
враження що вони
на скору руку
я відкрив підручник за восьмий клас
подивитися подивився закрив Сказав що ні
Я таке розповідати не буду на третьому
абзаці написано що ВВП 21 лютого прийняв
підписав указ про визнання так званих
ЛНР ДНР
Ну і що я должен це дітям казати ні я
такого не скажу Ну і все і на тому моя
робота і закінчилась
я не дивилась ні телебачення не слухала
їхні радіо не спілкувалася з ними тому
ми не мозок залишився чистим а от є люди
У мене навіть сусідка її син служить ЗСУ
вона прийшла і каже я буду класним
керівником у російській школі я говорю
як у ваш син служить як А вона Ти
понімаєш що Росія тут навсегда ми вже
нічого не зробимо нам прийдеться з цим
змиритися
Спасите сюди
[музика]
Я до останнього моменту
поки особистими очима не побачив
українських військових я не вірив що нас
звільнять
окупацією були прильоти коли веселу там
точечно там навіть у людей вікна він
ішов не шалилися а вже коли в нас йде
купували тоді вже почалося страшне Ну не
не дня не було Не жодного дня не було що
було тихо
героями можна бути в кіно а в житті
Насправді це дуже складно і дуже страшно
саме людям потрібно було вижити легко
казати тим хто виїхав кинули все кинути
все Ну як то кажуть це можна
звинувачувати людину а спробувати пожити
так як людина ця жила
той страх який вона пережила Не кожен
може
як показала нам наше життя Що хто хто
хто і хто
У нас є близько 200 кримінальних
проваджень щодо
колабораційних дій на колишній
окупованій території куп'янщини втік хто
ще не потрапили в поле можливо не
потрапили в поле зору правоохоронців до
них черга дійде
[музика]
ну Я например скажу как бы я не довольно
я многими вещами не довольно Потому что
если люди
работали при
окупации при тех которых захватили нашу
землю убивали людей там забирали
издевались Да мы сегодня видим что те
кто Пошли на Это сотрудничество они
сегодня работает при украинской власти
дуже мало залишилось людей і саме
кваліфікованих людей спеціалістів які
можуть виконувати ті чи інші завдання
які ми перед ними ставимо на жаль ті
люди які виїхали вони поки що не
повертаються
я тут їжджу роздаю допомагаю волонтер
грузим тут сортуємо підтримуємо
українців
як зайшли наші українські війська Ну я
розумів що мені будуть задавати питання
але я був в шоці від того як це робив
тобто приїхав мій товариш А разом з
іншими товаришем це наші спільні друзі з
Миколою і з ними військовий такий
кремезний дядько Він
без всяких пояснень Почав мене просто
бити в обличчя розвинені око з
малодушніча як він казав якщо ти не міг
виїхати ти мусив застрелитись
неприємне неприємно коли тебе б'ють
ті люди яких ти можна сказати чекав
раніше я себе вважав сміливою людиною
але в цій ситуації а значить я побачив
наскільки страшний сам страх
[музика]
Я з
Донецької області з міста Горлівка коли
в 14-му роки року почалися воєнні дії
мені довелося покинути своє місто та
переїхати в харківську область
ще раз це вже такий другий переїзд і
найбільше тяжкий та болючий тому що з
цим переїздом дуже багато чого зв'язано
тому і є
викрадання Миколи Тому це ця війна вона
[музика]